[applause]
>>Tim Harford: Thank you very much Cynthia.
Thanks everyone for coming.
I know there are lots of things going on on
campus that are interesting and distracting.
So I appreciate you taking the trouble to
turn out and listen to me.
One of the messages of the book "Adapt" is
that we should experiment in trying new things.
And that's the way that we solve complex problems.
So let me start with a little experiment.
Or at least testing the water.
There are three things that I could talk to
you about today.
I could focus on Chapter 1 of the book which
is about how we solve problems in a complex
world.
I could talk about Chapter 3 of the book which
is how we nurture innovations that matter.
Or I could talk about Chapter 6 in the book
which is how we prevent financial meltdowns.
So Chapter 1, problem solving in a complex
world.
Chapter 2, nurturing innovations that matter.
Chapter 3 preventing financial meltdown.
I just want a quick show of hands.
Who would prefer Chapter 1?
"Problem solving in a complex world?"
Okay, who would prefer Chapter 3?
"Nurturing innovations that matter?"
Who would prefer Chapter 6?
"Preventing financial meltdowns."
[laughter]
>>Harford: You are so East Coast.
>>Harford: So okay well it was kind of even.
Last night I spoke in Seattle and I asked
the same question and people, it was also
kind even.
And I talked about nurturing innovations that
matter.
So forgive me if purely to keep me you know
suitably inexperienced and capable of failure
I talk about the other subjects.
I talk about problem solving in a complex
world.
Since I think it was pretty much 50-50.
So why do I say the world's complex?
Let me start by telling the story of one of
my countrymen, a gentleman called, Thomas
Thwaites
Who set himself a very difficult task.
Thomas Thwaites wanted to make a toaster.
He wanted to make a toaster that was the equivalent
of a seven dollar toaster he could buy on
Main Street.
And, I'm not talking about making a toaster
from a toaster kit.
I mean, imagine this guy you know dressed
only in a loincloth armed with a penknife.
Ready to build a toaster from raw materials.
To dig the iron from out of the earth.
To carve the wood that goes into all good
toasters from the tree.
Whatever, to produce from raw materials this
pretty straightforward inexpensive consumer
product.
It turns out this is a pretty difficult project.
So the first thing he did was to buy a seven
dollar toaster and take it apart.
And he discovered that a toaster actually
contains over 400 components and subcomponents.
It contains a number of different materials.
It contains iron, nickel, copper, mica which
is a sort of slate like material that you
wrap the heating element around.
Plastic, plastic's very important.
If you didn't have plastic, how would you
have the beautiful sleek looking toaster casing?
There's also the whole electrocution issue.
It's kind of important.
So it's a hugely complex problem, so where
does he start?
Okay I'm gonna get iron.
So he's English.
Great Britain is a postindustrial country,
we don't actually have any iron mines anymore.
But he called a place and he said I'm trying
to make a toaster, can I come in.
So he visited this museum, it used to be an
iron mine now it's simply a museum of iron
mining.
And they very kindly gave him a bunch of iron
ore to fill.
He had one of these roll-on suitcases.
So he filled that with iron ore.
So then he had to turn iron ore into iron.
Well, I don't know, maybe somebody here knows
how you do that, but I'm not too clear.
So the first experiment there was he had this
big trashcan.
He had a leaf blower.
He had barbecue coals.
He's trying to use the leaf blower to sort
of blow air over the barbecue coals, get them
as hot as possible.
To try and smelt this iron.
That didn't work.
He then discovered, there was a fairly recent
patent for a new process to smelt iron.
And it turns out that you can smelt iron in
a microwave.
I do have the photos.
I should probably say I have the photos of
the second microwave.
[laughter]
>>Harford: The first microwave didn't survive
the experience.
[laughter]
>>Harford: But he did manage do the iron.
So then he just sort of went on with this
sort of process.
You'll have notice by the way, there was already
a compromise.
The purity of that initial vision, remember,
just to make the toaster with your bare hands
or maybe a Swiss Army knife.
And now he's using a microwave.
A microwave is clearly a more expensive complex
product than a toaster.
So there were some issues there, but let's
pass on.
And we'll come back to them.
So plastic.
Where does plastic come from?
Petroleum.
Where does petroleum come from?
BP, they got loads of it.
They spill it everywhere.
So he called BP and he said "Could I please
take a trip out to an oil rig?
I'll bring my own can, I'd like some crude
oil I'm gonna make some plastic."
They said no, I don't know why they said no.
You know some reason.
He did discover though there is a way of making
a kind of plastic from potato starch.
So he did that.
The trouble is, it's edible, so he lost half
of it to mold and the other half to snails.
And he finally got his plastic by just scavenging
some plastics from somewhere and melting it.
So again, he's kind of cheating.
The copper, he got from the water from a disused
copper mine by electrolysis.
So that's a fairly modern technique.
And the nickel, you wanna guess?
Where do you get nickel from?
[laughter]
>>Harford: Absolutely, you buy a Canadian
commemorative dollar.
It's 99.99% nickel.
And there's your nickel.
Very easy.
So he's making these compromises with his
original vision.
But you know, he said to me, "You know Tim,
I realize if you, if it was just you, and
you are just trying to make a toaster all
by yourself.
You could spend your whole life and you still
wouldn't get that."
Turns out it's basically an impossible problem.
And the toaster he eventually produced I don't
know how to describe it.
You know when you're a bit younger, it was
your birthday.
You might ask your Mom to do you a birthday
cake with a special shape.
So for me it was a ladybug.
Okay?
Just me, no one else ever got a birthday cake
and a special shape?
So okay imagine that you're getting your Mom
to produce you a specially shaped birthday
cake.
Or your dad, I'm not you know I'm modern.
I'm not judging.
So your Mom is producing this birthday cake.
And imagine you said "I want it in the shape
of a toaster Mom."
And imagine that your Mom did that.
And imagine that your Mom was also very very
drunk.
[laughter]
>>Harford: That's kind of what Thomas Thwaites
got with this sort of oozing dripping congealed
plastic coating on this toaster.
And he said to me, you know when I plug it
into a battery it does get warm.
But I am not sure what's gonna happen when
I plug it into the mains.
So he had a big exhibition.
He showed all the different things he had
done.
All the different experiments.
All the different items of equipment he done
to produce his toaster.
At the end of the exhibition they had a few
drinks and he plugged the toaster into the
mains.
2 seconds later the toaster was toast.
And I tell this story because it's worth pausing
a moment to think about the tremendous complexity
of the economy that surrounds us.
And therefore the society that surrounds us.
A pretty simple product like a toaster is
actually far beyond the capability of any
one person.
It's produced instead by a decentralized team
effort.
So the copper from the toaster might come
from say the Chuquicamata mine in Chile.
Where there's this guy who drives these gigantic
trucks you know.
You couldn't fit one into this room.
Huge huge trucks full of copper ore.
And he just goes around and around and around
this huge opencast mine.
As he's driving with his copper in the back
of his truck.
Maybe it's going to the toaster.
Maybe it's gonna make the casing of a bullet.
He doesn't know, he doesn't need to know.
He's just doing his part in that team effort.
That decentralized team effort.
And there are so many products.
So a reasonable educated guess in a ancestral
society.
A hunter gatherer society.
The kind of society where our brains evolved.
There might have been two or 300 distinct
products.
If you know this kind of flint knife, that
kind of flint knife.
This kind of loincloth, that kind of loincloth.
There's not a lot going on.
There's some interesting and complex challenges,
but not very many products in this economy.
So anybody want to guess how many products
are on sale in Starbucks.
Typical branch of Starbucks
>>female audience member #1: 60?
>>Harford: 60.
Ok, so Starbucks, that makes a hunter gatherer
society five times more complex than a Starbucks.
Let's have a guess.
Put your hands up if you think there are more
than 60.
Hands up if you think there are fewer than
60.
Okay so we've got one at 60, we've got I think
one say fewer than 60.
Alright let's have a higher estimate than
60 then since most of you think it's more
than 60.
>>male audience member #1: 1000
>>Harford: 1000
Okay so hands up if you think it's more than
1000.
Hands up if you think it's fewer than 1000.
Okay so it was good were kind of between 60
and 1000.
Good, well done.
Turns out according to Starbucks there are
85,000 products on sale in a typical Starbucks.
>>female audience member #2: On sale?
>>Harford: On sale in a typical Starbucks.
I mean, they get to cheat right, because it's
combinatorial.
I mean every different squirt of goop creates
a different product.
But let's cheat a bit less.
Let's think about Wal-Mart.
Okay, they can't create a new product by sort
of adding marshmallows.
Number of products on sale in a typical Walmart
is about 100,000.
And the number of products, distinct products.
By which I mean product that you'd need a
different barcode for each product.
Okay?
So distinctive types of product.
You change the color of the jeans, or you
change the cut, or you change the size and
you've got a different product.
How many different barcodes would you need?
How many different products in the Bay area?
Anyone want to guess?
There's a guy who's thought about this quite
hard.
Eric Beinhocker at McKinsey, he's pretty smart.
Any guess?
6 million.
Okay let's put hands up.
More than 6 million?
Fewer than 6 million?
Okay and most people have no idea, that's
fair enough.
[laughter]
>>Harford: It is more than 6 million.
It's actually more than 6 billion.
You're out by about three orders of magnitude.
It's about 10 billion.
Distinct products and services on sale in
the Bay Area.
And it has more types of products and there
are people I suspect.
That's the complexity of the economy that
surrounds us.
Now if I were, if I were just in my economist
mode.
And this was a stage.
I would say, "Wow the economy is very complicated
and very impressive."
And it's decentralized.
Barack Obama doesn't run it.
Bill Gates doesn't run it.
Wall Street doesn't run it.
Nobody runs it.
It's a decentralized system.
No one's in control, and it produces these
amazing things.
We get toasters for seven dollars.
You could never make that in your whole life
if you try.
You could devote your entire life to making
a toaster you still wouldn't do it.
And this is the complexity of the economy
that surrounds us.
And it's magnificent, and it's wonderful,
and let's leave it at that shall we?
And just thumbs up for the market.
And, you know there's a point there.
There really is a point.
And yet.
Does anybody in this room think that the world
is currently perfect?
Okay, no votes.
We have problems.
We have some serious problems facing us.
I think that we have a problem with the kind
of innovation that we produce.
I think there's certain kinds of innovation
we're very good at producing.
I think there are certain others.
A lot of medical innovations, we still don't
have that HIV vaccine that President Reagan's
Health Secretary promised us back in 1984.
We still don't have that cost competitive
clean energy system we've been sort of talking
about for the last 30 years.
I mean, I understand you did do your bit this
morning well done.
But we haven't solved that yet.
We have innovation problems.
We have environmental problems, severe environmental
problems.
There are wars.
You may have noticed some minor disruption
on Wall Street recently.
You know we've got problems.
And that's just, that's just in the Western
world.
Let alone Sub-Saharan Africa.
So, these are big problems.
And Thomas Thwaites' toaster is, because it's
a symbol of the sophistication of our economy
and our society it is also a symbol of the
hurdles and obstacles that lie in wait for
people who want to change it and make it better.
And that's the challenge I want to talk to
you about today.
Now, I think the world's only gonna become
more complex.
And I think the way we tend to think about
these problems is not necessarily terribly
helpful.
So we tend to be very focused on a leadership
model.
We can find the right leader with the right
ideas.
You know these problems would be solved.
And Barack Obama is not going to solve all
our problems and he knows he's not gonna solve
all our problems.
I loved his first speech to the White House
press corps after he was elected President.
He sort of mocked the expectations that everybody
had of him.
And he said, " I'm very proud of the things
we've achieved in my first hundred days but
I now want to talk to you about what I propose
to achieve in my second hundred days."
"And my second hundred days I will design
and build a library devoted to the achievements
of my first hundred days."
[laughter]
Harford: "And my second hundred days will
be so successful, they will be completed in
only 72 days."
"And on the 73rd day I will rest."
So he was mocking these expectations.
And in his autobiography he says change doesn't
come from the top.
Change comes from a mobilized grassroots.
And the reason that he said that is in a world
where there are 10 billion products in the
Bay Area, there are 100,000 products in a
Wal-Mart.
Where any one of those products would be as
complex as a toaster or much more complex
than a toaster.
Where we don't really understand how it all
fits together.
Where no one person can track how it's all
going, how it all works.
He understands that there are limits to top-down
solutions to our problems.
And you might say well fine, no one man or
it usually is a man, no one woman, no one
person is gonna be able to provide the leadership
to get us through this.
But maybe with the right expert advice.
With smart enough people, they could just
figure out solutions to these problems.
And I think, clearly that is true in certain
spirited endeavor.
But I think in most of the problems that really
interest us the social problems, the problems
of Social Science.
A Social Science expertise has a limited track
record.
I know that Philip Tetlock the psychologist
has come here and spoken at Google.
If you didn't see him, you should check out
his talk on Authors@Google.
Tetlock is a fascinating researcher who has
wrestled for 25 years with the question of
expert judgment in the Social Sciences.
And to cut a tremendous, wonderful story short.
What Tetlock did to test out the question
of expert judgment in Social Sciences was
to round up experts of every field in the
Social Sciences.
From academia and more practical people, diplomats,
journalists, spies, policy wonks, think tankers.
And ask, and there were economists, sociologists,
anthropologists, political scientists, historians.
He would ask them to make forecasts.
About the future of the world.
In all its guises.
Economic forecast, political forecasts.
Forecast about their area of expertise.
Forecasts outside their area of expertise.
Short-term and long-term.
The point is, these forecasts were all quantifiable.
What Tetlock wanted to do was what we so rarely
do.
Which was to come back later and call people
on what they had actually predicted.
And what he found in a nutshell was, you might
as well have asked an orangutan because they
would have done just as good a job as any
of these experts.
And he found certain patterns in the data
about who gives really bad forecasts and who
give slightly better forecast.
But basically, experts can't forecast it doesn't
matter what field you're talking about.
In the Social Sciences.
Now at this point, a lot of people have said,
'cause Tetlock's work has become quite famous.
"Well that just goes to show, you can't trust
the experts.
You know, do it yourself."
Well I'm not convinced about this.
I mean I'm not, if I ever need say heart surgery
I am not going to propose that I just ask
my wife to do it.
You know I'm gonna ask a heart surgeon.
Tomorrow I'm flying to Toronto.
I would like the pilot to be an expert.
Yeah?
It's not, it's simply not good enough to say
do it yourself experts are useless.
It's not really a statement about the nature
of expertise.
It's a statement about the complexity of the
world that we can't forecast it.
There are always gonna be surprises.
We can make plans, we can consult experts
to try and solve these problems that I'm talking
about.
And we will constantly be surprised.
So fine.
How do we solve problems then?
How do we solve complex problems?
Well one possibility is to think about a problem
that I think we have nailed.
And to look at how it's been solved.
And I think a problem that we've fixed is
the problem of material affluence.
We certainly fixed that problem here at Mountain
View.
And I think we've basically fixed that problem
in the Western world.
And it's a problem that's not easy to fix.
It's a problem that defeated feudalism; it's
a problem that defeated Soviet Union and Communist
China.
It's a problem that human societies have been
wrestling with for you know 25,000 years or
so.
Providing just enough stuff to keep people
happy.
Clothes to wear, place to sleep, food to eat,
and we've solved it.
And think about the toaster.
This is not a problem to trivialize.
It's a very very hard problem.
Okay.
How did we solve it?
Well you could say we solved it, we solved
it with a big reliance on private businesses.
Okay so, what's the trick?
So I've asked a number of private business
people about this and they say well the reason
that private business solved problem so well
is because people who work for private businesses
are very very smart.
Especially me.
And I'm not so sure about that.
I mean I could understand if you read business
week or Forbes and Fortune they will tell
you that businesses are run by very smart
people.
And that's why they do amazing things.
And they'll tell you about the new CEO of
this company or that company and how clever
they are.
And then of course half the time they get
sacked three years later with a huge payoff
having totally failed to do anything of any
consequence.
That's actually not the problem-solving algorithm
at work.
What is the problem?
Is not hire smart people.
That's just experts all over again.
What is the problem-solving algorithm?
Well here's a clue.
In 1982 Tom Peters who since became a huge
larger-than-life management guru.
Published a book called "In search of excellence."
And the book was a huge business bestseller.
It was about the 43 most excellent companies
in America.
And what we can all learn from them.
So we learn from their marketing,
their advertising, their human resources policy.
You know, how do they run their businesses
and what can the rest of the world learn from
these 43 excellent American businesses?
Fine.
Three years later, Business Week had a cover
story.
"Oops, Who's Excellent Now?"
And almost a third of those excellent companies
were in financial trouble just three years
later.
I would love to turn this into a story about
how Tom Peters is a silly man.
But it's not really a story about how Tom
Peters is a silly man.
It's a story about failure in business.
It's ubiquitous.
We go all the way back to the Johannes Gutenberg.
He's really cool again suddenly.
He's sort of the symbol of you know web two,
web three or wherever we're up to these days.
The invention of the movable type printing
press.
So Gutenberg invents, in a way he invents
the modern world.
By making it possible to print books.
And he creates this fantastic object, the
42 line Bible.
The Gutenberg Bible.
Only a few copies out there exist.
And it's this beautiful printed Bible.
That many people regard as one of the most
remarkable books in the history of Western
civilization.
What is not often commented on is that Gutenberg's
Bible bankrupted Johannes Gutenberg.
He got into debt.
He got into an argument with his business
partner.
And that was it.
He was gone.
He was a failure.
In many ways.
He was a success as far as we're all concerned.
But in his own life he failed as a business
person.
And it turns out; actually printing Bibles
is not necessarily what you want to do.
Logically you would think, I developed this
fantastic new technology.
You can print books.
What is the greatest book in the world?
The Bible.
That's the name you know.
It means "the book."
I will print the Bible.
It turns out people don't want that kind of
you know off-the-shelf GMO of cookie-cutter
Bible.
They want a beautiful organic hand stitched
monk crafted illuminated Bible.
So it's not a good business model.
And the early printing industry suffered despite
the fact it should be an amazing fast-growing
industry.
Should've been the Silicon Valley of the day.
It suffered tremendously high failure rates.
Enormously high.
Does anyone want to guess what it was that
the printing industry eventually figured out
was the business model that would work?
>>male audience member #2: A novel?
>>Harford: No it wasn't a novel.
Newspapers?
A lot of people say newspapers, it's not newspapers.
>>female audience member #3: Tabloids?
It's not, it's closer, it's getting closer
but it's still not very close.
Sorry?
>>male audience member #3: Propaganda?
>>male audience member #4: Advertisements?
>>Harford: Neither advertisements nor propaganda.
But both are closer.
>>female audience member #4: Pamphlets?
>>Harford: They were a kind of pamphlet.
They were papal indulgences.
Okay, so it's a certificate from the Pope
that gets you into heaven earlier.
It's like a little letter to St. Peter which
you buy and its great business for the medieval
Catholic Church.
And you think about it, you think of course
that is the perfect thing.
You set up your printing press once and you're
good to go.
You can stamp these things out.
You just need a signature from a Catholic
official, or a seal.
No one really cares that they're not properly
handwritten.
It doesn't matter.
What matters is that they have spiritual value
and financial value.
And that was the early business model of the
printing industry.
Having just stumbled through most of the suggestions
that you came up with.
So it's not always obvious where success in
business is gonna come from.
And failure rates are very high.
And despite these failure rates, we have solved
this problem of material affluence.
Actually I would say not despite these failure
rates, because of these failure rates
There's actually some very interesting studies
showing that corporate turnover, by which
I mean.
So you look at the top 10 largest employees
in a country and how often do employees drop
off that list and are they replaced by other
companies.
That's positively related to economic growth.
And productivity growth.
And it seems to be causal.
Because, you look at turnover in say 1970,
that turn and that's a good predictor of economic
growth throughout the 1970s.
You look at turn in 1980, you're comparing
one country with another, that's a good prediction
of economic growth throughout the 1980s.
So I said despite this failure we've solved
the material affluence problem.
I would say we've solved the material affluence
problem because of this failure.
Because it's an evolutionary system.
It's a trial and error system.
It's a trial and error system that is extremely
robust in the face of failure.
You can have 50 failures.
And if one of the successes is, you can have
one success and if it's General Electric that's
fine.
That's good odds.
So I think these trial and error mechanisms
are very important.
The market is one.
The scientific method is another.
Again you can have a lot of theoretical failures
, you can have a lot of experimental failures,
but you will get your way towards progress.
And one success makes up for a lot of failures.
So this is how I think problems are solved
in a complex world.
Through trial and error.
The problem is psychologically, organizationally
politically, this is a message a lot of people
find very difficult to accept.
Think about the incentives for politicians.
So I said a moment ago in a well-functioning
market you have 50 failures, one success,
that's fine.
Think about politics.
Give me a politician, 50 things can be going
right.
You have one embarrassing problem.
One policy failure of any description.
You know what the agenda for the next election
campaign is gonna be.
The media will talk about your failure; your
opponents will talk about your failure.
And so while in robust trial and error systems
we say well were happy to have 50 failures
for one success in political systems it's
absolutely the reverse.
50 successes don't necessarily make up for
one failure.
So politicians have very different incentives.
The basic incentive is, don't ever do anything.
And if you do do something, for goodness sake
don't ever measure whether you'll succeed
or not.
Don't define targets.
Don't specify what is needed to be qualified
as a success.
And above all, do not evaluate.
Because an awful lot of stuff goes wrong.
Many things fail in a complex world.
And well goodness me the last thing you want
to do is to actually create data that could
enable one of your opponents to say that you
had certifiably produced a failure.
And I said that's a problem that affects politics.
I think it affects organizations in a broader
sense.
So it's an office politics problem as well
as a politics from.
In the book I talk about how the U.S. Army
adapted basically an impossible situation
in Iraq with a failing strategy from the top.
And it was the guys much further down who
could see what was going on, could see the
failures and tried to improvise more effective
tactics.
And what's fascinating is that once they did
that, the people at the top of the Army still
didn't want to know.
But their peers did want to know.
Their peers were hungry for information about
what was working.
And so you had counterinsurgency tips being
passed around between the majors and the colonels
and captains in Iraq.
You know like a naughty magazine amongst schoolboys.
[Whispering] Don't tell the guys up there,
but this is pretty good stuff you know.
This work in Tal Afa you should try it in
Al Anbar province.
And that's how better counterinsurgency tactics
spread around the Army.
Because we just don't have the incentives
for the hierarchy to experiment.
It's not just a hierarchical problem.
I think it's a personal problem.
It's a personal problem that manifests itself
in hierarchies.
Manifests itself in policies.
And it also manifests itself in our lives.
So you understand the manifestation in politics
of this.
You know we don't like uncertainty.
We like somebody to tell us that he knows
or she knows what's going on.
I lived in the states during the Bush-Kerry
Presidential election campaign.
You may remember that election campaign.
It was effectively fought between the guy
who could make up mind and the guy who couldn't
make up its mind.
And the people who wanted to defend the guy
who could make up his mind, the defense was,
no he can make up his mind.
Nobody ever said "Well complex problem maybe
you should be changing your mind."
In the UK.
The two most successful postwar politicians
are Margaret Thatcher and Tony Blair.
Between them they won six general elections.
They won three each.
So this is the equivalent, I know it's not
constitutionally possible, it's the equivalency
of winning three presidential elections.
So these two people had as much election success
between them as President Reagan, President
Clinton, and President George W. Bush put
together.
So those are pretty effective political operators.
You know what one of Margaret Thatcher's most
famous statements?
"You turn if you want to, the lady's not for
turning, I can't turn around."
One of Blair's most famous political statements.
"I don't have a reverse gear."
Okay so I'd like to sell you a car, it doesn't
turn, it doesn't reverse.
You want it?
[laughter]
>>Harford: No you don't.
But you want the politician, it seems that
we do.
We like that expression of certainty.
We don't like a politician who says I don't
know, is complex.
You know, we might have a good idea, but we're
gonna need to test it out.
We're gonna need to experiment.
We may have to fail 50 times before we get
one success, but it'll be worth it.
Stick with me.
Oh is anybody still there?
It's a problem, it's a problem.
We have this difficulty.
And I was quite struck by the fact that in
the UK perhaps the most important Social Scientist
of the last decade turns out to be a celebrity
chef.
So, and he's an accidental Social Scientist.
So Jamie Oliver, I know Jamie's trying to
make it big here in the US now.
So Jamie a few years ago was a hugely successful
celebrity chef.
Launches this campaign for better school food.
Now okay, I want you to think about something
horrible for a moment.
School food.
English food.
[laughter]
>>Harford: English school food.
>>Harford: It's not good.
So Jamie's campaigning to improve the situation.
And he has this big TV show.
And you know he teaches the staff at the schools
how to teach, or how to cook all this you
know great fresh stuff.
And he tries to convince the kids to stop
eating sort of emulsified high-fat awful foods.
And chugging down sugary fizzy drinks.
And start eating something a bit healthier.
But before he does this.
In preparation for this campaign.
He teams up with the London Borough of Greenwich.
This is a big sort of chunk of London.
Several hundred thousand people.
And he convinces the educational authority
there to change the menus in all the schools.
He says, "I'm gonna redesign your menus and
I'm gonna mobilize resources for you."
"And I'm gonna help train the staff."
"And it's gonna be great."
But this is all basically happening in Greenwich
it's not happening anywhere else.
There's no TV campaign it's all pretty much
under the radar.
And then he makes his TV show.
And this one school in Greenwich has TV cameras
everywhere and massive disruption.
Every other school in Greenwich has basically
just had this exogenous shock dropped in there.
Jamie Oliver's menus.
So the food is better.
For no reason other than just Jamie happened
to come along and pick Greenwich.
And the food hasn't changed anywhere else
in London; it's only changed in Greenwich.
Suddenly these kids are eating salads.
And they don't know what's hit them.
Then a couple of economists come along and
they say, "Jamie kind of created a controlled
trial there."
I mean it wasn't a proper sort of full year
double-blind randomized controlled trial.
But it was, it was pretty good.
He basically took London and he carved out
an area and he said "We're gonna change the
menus there.
There's no reason why we changed the menus
there rather than anywhere else."
Observationally there's no obvious difference
between Greenwich and anywhere else.
So economists came along and said "Well what
difference did it make?"
And although the data was imperfect and uncertain
the evidence seems to be well fewer authorized
absences.
Authorized absences basically, a kid gets
sick.
So less illness.
Higher scores in maths, higher scores in reading.
Kids are basically able to concentrate better,
they're a bit smarter.
Now the British Prime Minister at the time
and the leader of the Opposition at the time
both fell over themselves to say what a wonderful
guy Jamie Oliver was and what a wonderful
idea this was.
And I find that pretty exasperating.
Tony Blair praising Jamie Oliver had been
the Prime Minister for eight years.
It wasn't a particularly radical idea, it
existed in theory for a couple of decades
that maybe nutrition has an effect on childhood
outcomes and childhood learning.
He could've run that experiment.
He could've run that experiment properly.
In fact he could've run 100 experiments.
He could've run 1000 experiments.
But he chose not to do so.
And why, I don't know.
Maybe the idea of experimenting on the children.
Maybe the idea that he basically, he thought
he knew the answer.
The god-complex in medics.
With medics who believe they know the answer.
But slowly but surely we've come to realize
you need to run experiments.
One of the heroes of the book.
And there was, basically every chapter in
the book has a hero and the reason every chapter
has a hero is because it turns out experimenting,
trying something new, taking risks is whether
you're a colonel in Iraq, or your choreographer,
or you are doing research into gene therapy.
It's extremely difficult.
You're gonna get a lot of hassle.
You're not gonna get much support.
You need to be very brave, very stubborn to
do this kind of thing.
That's why, there's a hero.
One of the heroes in the book is a doctor
called Archie Cochrane.
Who later, his name has been given to this
amazing organization called the Cochrane Collaboration
which pulls together information about basically
all the information we have about all the
medical treatments out there.
Evaluated and put together in a systematic
fashion.
So we really have the best possible information
about what medical treatments work and what
don't.
But Cochrane who also smuggled vitamins into
a prisoner of war camp in World War II because
he was a prisoner.
The other prisoners, they're all dying of
something and he didn't know what.
So he managed to smuggle in vitamins and run
a randomized trial in the prisoner of war
camp.
Then go to the German running the camp with
his graphs and say.
And actually it turns out what these men actually
need is Marmite.
It contains vitamin B-12.
It's a sort of yeast extract, it looks like
crude oil.
And although the relations in that camp were
unbelievably bad between the prisoners and
guards.
The guards, one of the young guards who was
a doctor said, "It's a war crime if we don't
respond to this evidence."
"This cannot be denied."
"The evidence that's come from this trial."
"And you have to supply these men with vitamins
or you are murdering them."
And the next day, the vitamins turned up at
the camp.
Evidence has a tremendous power.
But one of the things that Cochrane did to
emphasize the importance of running experiments
and running trials was he.
This was after the war.
He tried to get his colleagues who were running
cardiac recuperation wings to see whether
maybe patients who had cardiac surgery maybe
should be recuperating at home.
And they all said this is tremendously unethical,
you can't do this, you're gonna to kill people.
And they managed to shut down the trial.
And he managed to get it open in a different
city.
So he's running this trial.
He calls all the doctors together around the
table and he says, "Well gentlemen I have
some early results."
"They're not statistically significant, but
I think we can see which way the wind is blowing."
"And it turns out that the patients who are
recuperating at home seem to be more likely
to die."
"It's excess mortality there."
"We can't be sure of this because it's too
early."
And there's this huge hubbub and they all
said, "We always that you are completely unethical
you need to shut this trial down at once you're
killing people."
And he let them carry on for a bit.
And he said, "Oh well that's very interesting
because I just swapped the two tables and
it turns out your cardiac wings are the ones
that seems to be killing people."
"Should we shut them down now?"
"Or do you want to wait until we finish the
experiment?
He understood that these experiments produce
a lot of data.
So we've mostly won that fight in medicine.
We've hardly begun to wage that fight in economic
policy.
In criminal justice.
In education.
To run randomized trials.
They produce a tremendous amount of information.
But you know the book isn't just about these
formal trials, it's about all the different
institutions we use to run experiments.
Formal experimentation and informal experimentation.
In the end though we find this tough.
Look at the psychological evidence about how
we feel about failure.
We're very sensitive to it.
Even a small failure we, we put disproportionate
weight on it.
We go into a fit of denial.
Which is why these randomized trials are so
powerful.
We, there's a failure going on, but we refuse
to admit that there's a denial.
I interviewed poker players for the book among
many other people.
And they told me at the poker table what's
really dangerous is immediately after you've
had a failure at the table you then start
taking risks, 'cause you want to get your
money back.
So you respond to failure in a very unconstructive
ways.
It's why the old clich where you should
learn from your mistakes is a clich.
We keep saying learn from your mistakes, learn
from your mistakes.
Why do we keep saying it?
Because we don't learn from our mistakes,
we find it very hard.
So that's what the book is about.
It's a recognition that we have complex problems.
That they are too hard to solve from a purely
theoretical basis.
It's not that failure is desirable.
Failure sucks, you know.
It's that failure is going to happen.
It's inevitable in a complex world.
And the sooner that we get used to that in
our personal lives as voters, as employees.
And above all the sooner were able to develop
institutions capable of experimenting.
Capable of engaging in trial and error.
Whether it's very tightly controlled or whether
it's very loose.
The sooner were able to do that.
The sooner we'll be able to solve problems
in a complex world.
I'm very happy to take questions, but thank
you all for listening.
[applause]
So a question here?
>>male audience member #5: Thank you very
much.
I wanted to ask you a question regarding the
psychology of people.
'Cause it seems like you're setting up framework
that's theoretical, very rational.
But at the end it's gonna be human beings
that are operating it.
And so there are two examples of psychology
that I think would impede the ability to do
this.
Cannamen proved in his studies that people
value losses twice as much as the gains.
Right?
So there's a bias to loss avoidance.
They're not viewed as equal.
The other thing is people presented with a
great deal of choice, they don't actually
enjoy it.
It actually causes unhappiness.
When they have more choice.
So giving them six flavors is actually better
than 30 flavors.
'Cause they always feel like, I could've picked
a better flavor.
And if there's six, I can easily sample, I
can't sample all 30 or 100 or 100,000 products
or whatever it is, right?
And so, you're talking about running many
many many experiments.
How many experiments can I really run?
How many choices can I really have?
If I track infinity experiments, I can't possibly
deal with it, right?
And then there's a near infinity of losses
that I'll suffer in all the failures, right?
So you know loss avoidance.
So just thinking that these two examples of
human psychology that are well proven right?
Would tend to lead you down paths where you
really won't be able to do a whole lot of
experiments.
Because you don't want to suffer the losses
and you don't want to deal with the complexity
of the choices.
>>Harford: I half agree with you.
So I certainly agree with the point about
loss aversion which is something that I catered
to at the end of the talk emphasizing that
we do.
We seem to significantly overweigh losses.
Maybe from an evolutionary point of view that
used to be rational.
But in our comfortable sort of modern world
that's not rational and we need to figure
out ways to deal with that.
I don't accept the result on excess choice.
Okay?
It's not robust.
There are lots of studies disagreeing with
this.
Benjamin Scheibehenne recently published a
systematic review of this.
And found on average no effect.
We don't understand that result very well.
And I think just intuitively, we all get very
excited about this idea that choice is bad
and choices demotivate and choice distracts.
But Wal-Mart is still doing fine, Starbucks
offer 85,000 products.
I mean there's clearly something.
There's something there, but there's something
wrong as well.
>>male audience member #5: Brand availability.
>>Harford: Well.
There are various ways that this choice is
mediated.
But my point is, well actually it does make
a larger point about the value of experimentation.
Which is, actually we need very good systems
for replicating experiments.
Because you get experiment like the "choice
is bad" experiment.
Which is a very creative and professionally
run experiment.
It's all above board, it's all very rigorous
and peer-reviewed.
But you have to replicate, and it turns out
this one is hard to replicate.
And that happens a lot.
Your bigger point I think is this can be overwhelming.
We don't like taking gambles.
And in order to be effective, we need to take
a lot of gambles.
So, on a personal basis, that's absolutely
true.
I mean I argue that we probably should take
more risks in our personal lives than we do.
We have such fun with, college students have
a great time because they are experimenting
and failing in a safe place.
Where those experiments though matter.
And then you, you know you quit college and
you get to your first job.
And I think many people have the experience
of suddenly trying really hard not to fail.
And then suddenly it's miserable.
It should be just like college right?
You got new colleagues, new surroundings,
new city, new ideas.
It should be just as fun as college, but actually
its failure reverse instead of failure friendly.
So I think we maybe should experiment more
than we do in our personalized.
But that's almost an afterthought in the book.
The book is about building systems to experiment.
And we have systems that experiment.
Markets are a very good system for experimentation.
I'm not pro-market nut.
But markets do experiment.
And one of the reasons that you've got this
huge diversity.
Entrepreneurs don't view themselves as carrying
out 100,000 experiments; they might just carry
out one.
They may be delusional.
I mean there's good reason to believe that
many entrepreneurs are delusional about their
chances of success.
But socially that's fine, we ride off that
experiment.
So those experiments that are going on.
So some the themes in the book are about taking
that market process which we know is pretty
effective.
And directing it to more socially useful uses.
Can we direct those market processes to reducing
carbon emissions?
Can we direct those market processes to producing
vaccines for the poor?
And the scientific method to.
So I talk about how to fund scientist, or
how to run an organization in a way where
you are supporting people in taking risks.
And I'll just give you one example.
This is a classic example from economic history.
One of the most important inventions in the
economic history was Limited Liability Company.
Basically it means that if your company goes
bankrupt.
There's a limit to how far shareholders and
creditors can come after you personally.
Many economic historians think this was hugely
important in the development of modern Capitalism.
But what is it?
A system for reducing the downside of failure
and encouraging people to take risks.
Because socially, those risks are useful.
>>male audience member #6: So I like to irritate
people who don't believe in evolution by asking
them rather their difficulty is with death,
with sex or the idea that children take after
their parents.
You seem to be telling us today that death
is actually something we should accept and
embrace, and sex is something we should have
more of.
And I was wondering if you could tell us more
about the mechanisms whereby children take
after their parents.
Is it the biological evolution in fact, the
big driver in the long term is that fine tuning
different mechanisms to enhance themselves
[Inaudible]
>>Harford: That's a very good question, and
of course we all should be having more sex,
I think we all know that.
So the evolutionary metaphor I think is probably
more than metaphor, I think it's a proper
analogy that's very useful for understanding
how markets work.
What's essential to evolution is, and I'm
not a biologist so I'm not gonna give any
lessons on this.
The variation in selection.
There are lots of stuff, lots of different
stuff.
And then some mechanisms for getting rid of
the bad stuff and having more the good stuff.
We know that's a very powerful algorithm in
biology.
And it potentially is a very powerful how
the algorithm outside biology,
I talk about the work of Karl Sims who's probably
better known these days as the guy who did
the special effects for Spiderman and Lord
of the Rings and Titanic.
Originally he was programming evolution, really
cool evolution in digital environments.
If you go onto YouTube and type Karl Sims
virtual creatures you see some cool stuff
that he was programming nearly 20 years ago.
In markets.
So where does the variation come from?
Well it comes from entrepreneurs.
It also comes from middle managers.
Basically anybody in an organization was a
new idea for a new way to do things.
It can come from customer suggestions.
It could also come, it could be technological
as an input into economy.
So it can come from scientist.
It can come from research labs.
So there's no shortage of variation in well-functioning
economy.
In Wall Street, what you have is it turns
out everybody taking the same multi-trillion
dollar bet at the same time.
So we don't have sufficient variation on Wall
Street.
But generally markets create variation.
Where does the selection mechanism come from?
Well bankruptcy is a pretty good one.
If you don't close down the bad idea, you
know I'm gonna open a stuffed puppy shop okay.
Yeah, if the market doesn't buy on the stuffed
puppies then you're gonna close 'em down or
you're gonna change what you do and if you
don't the bankruptcy courts soon will.
What's the propagation mechanism, well there
are various ones.
So companies don't have sex, but companies
do merge.
Takeover other companies and rollout their
ideas inside those other companies.
They grow organically.
You know you just have more and more chains
of a particular retail store.
They just get copied.
You have a good idea, other people will try
to copy the idea.
And employees leave and set up their own organizations.
So you've got a variation mechanism.
You've got a selection mechanism.
You've got a propagation mechanism.
As it's an evolutionary environment.
Just a final thought.
It's a very interesting work by economist
Paul Ormerod.
Examining corporate extinctions and comparing
them to biological extinctions.
And actually the patterns are extremely similar.
They both, if you sort of arrange them properly
they both follow a power law.
And Ormerod's conclusion, I don't think this
is proven but I think it's strongly suggested
is we know evolution is a blind process.
There's no foresight.
Species don't decide a direction in which
to evolve.
It's just purely the variation selection.
Ormerod reckons that that is probably largely
true of economic organizations to.
No matter how much we pay our CEOs, they're
basically just experimenting pretty much randomly
and succeeding or failing pretty much randomly.
That's not proven but I think it's pretty
nicely suggested.
So do we have time for one more question?
You gonna have to ask me the question after
this Cynthia.
Thanks very much everybody for listening.
[applause]